[Musica]
quando mi è stato chiesto di partecipare
a questo evento mi sono reso conto che è
una bella occasione per esprimere così
liberamente ma anche maniera pacata
intelligente delle riflessioni a me come
ovvio come immaginate capita spesso di
esprimere così il mio pensiero in vari
tipi di consessi di assemblee sia
ovviamente di natura religiosa che anche
non è allora avevo questo questo tema il
tema delle sovrastrutture che che in
qualche modo incombono sulla persona
sull'essere umano quando affronta un
tema a partire da una
un'indicazione da un titolo cerco sempre
di declinare
di andare a vedere un po il significato
le parole di girarle e questo termine
sovrastruttura
se andiamo a indagare un pochino ci
accorgiamo che fu per primo karl marx
che l'ha usato che indicava con questa
parola tutto quello che si produce tutto
quello che è prodotto
dalla letteratura della filosofia anche
dalla teologia
però poi max arrivo a una ovviamente a
una critica radicale
e faceva poi consistere tutto in questa
sovrastruttura che diventa il male
diventa un po una sorta di male assoluto
e l'interesse economico
intuizioni interessanti
l'ideologia diventa qualcosa che stringe
che stritola l'essere umano poi lui come
tutti gli altri poi si accorgono ci si
accorge nel tempo e nella storia che si
cade molto facile cadere in questo
discorso di un'ideologia che anche se la
volevi superare ma di fatto poi ti in
trappola dopo di lui solo così per
citare qualche
scienza degli studi
dell'ultimo anno di liceo di filosofia
la scuola di francoforte horkheimer mark
uso
benjamin che in qualche modo in questa
loro critica alla società questo cito
questi autori perché ovviamente
venendo proprio da questa parola dal
pensiero di marx e loro l'hanno
recuperata dell'anno elaborata una
società in cui dicevano questi esponenti
della sua francoforte da cui gli dei
sono fuggiti in cui si rischiava di
considerare solo gli aspetti materiali
della realtà dimenticando la creatività
la spiritualità perdendo tutto il resto
facendo un passo indietro un altro
filosofo che a me a me molto caro e che
ho avuto modo a suo tempo un pochino di
approfondire di leggere kirk ad hoc che
nell'ottocento pensava che struttura per
lui il tuffo totale assoluto nella fede
che sola può eliminare quella spina
nella carne di paolina memoria dico
paolina in riferimento a una lettera di
san paolo e precisamente la seconda e
goines in cui in un passo
particolarmente celebre ma anche secondo
me estremamente importante san paolo san
paolo dice che gli è stata messa una
spina nella carne per non montare il
superbia una spina di il cui significato
è aperto non lo sappiamo non san paolo
non lo dice che cosa voleva dire con la
spina
eppure rimasta nel pensiero rimasta
nell'immaginario collettivo di
tantissimi e anche chi
sentiva premere questa spina nella vita
fin dall'infanzia per colpa ereditate
dal padre è l'unica soluzione per lui
era quella di affidarsi a dio nei
confronti del quale l'unico
atteggiamento da dea il timore e tremore
anche qui l'espressione che ha dato
mandato il titolo ha una sua opera molto
famoso
quando siamo questa parola
sovrastruttura pensiamo immediatamente
al condizionamento e di solito gli diamo
una connotazione negativa perché
nell'immaginario collettivo il
condizionamento è un torto una
limitazione nei confronti della libertà
e dell'autonomia a volte resta come
termine confuso ambiguo vari significati
un condizionamento incide sul
comportamento di ciascuno di noi
può arrivare a livello della coscienza
può
ingabbiarci con mette in discussione
quella che chiamiamo libertà individuale
dei coscienze che credo tutti quanti
pensiamo la pensiamo come qualcosa di
necessario di importante quindi questo
scilla zione da questa riflessione
stiamo facendo ci porta a pensare
le due realtà cioè condizionamento
sovrastrutture che condizionano o
libertà dove siamo sovrastrutture quindi
è quello che si mette in mezzo si
frappone come un muro alla realizzazione
di una vita autentica degna di essere
vissuta in quanto tale però sempre
ritenuto e pensato questo che ognuno di
noi io per primo ovviamente
quando nasciamo siamo nati in un
contesto particolare concreto
fatto di cose e persone reali tra
l'altro senza sceglierlo ci siamo
ritrovati alla vita
qualcun altro ci ha chiamato per noi
credenti siamo chiamati alla vita da dio
o perché dai nostri genitori per chi non
crede comunque ci siamo e siamo qui non
possiamo
negarci allora quello che ci circonda
quindi il luogo dove nasce e tutto
quello che ti porta poi nel cammino
della crescita a diventare quello che
sei
tante cose si dipendono da noi ma tante
no gli insegnamenti che ha ricevuto
esperienze situazioni che hai vissuto
un piccolo inciso ricordo maniera e lo
ricordo che l'ho detto tante volte hanno
raccontato nell'esperienza quando sono
stato parroco a roma tra le varie
esperienze parecchi anni quasi dieci
anni in una parrocchia di estrema
periferia dove purtroppo quando vedevo
nascere certi bambini parliamo di
italiani e non parliamone di stranieri
né di altre situazioni diversi italiani
che quando nascevano io vi devo nascere
in quel contesto
e già sapevo che sarebbero stati
indirizzati verso di sé purtroppo
negative e quindi delinquenza eccetera
eccetera
questo da una parte quindi questo ti fa
capire come la realtà in cui nasci non è
un dettaglio è qualcosa che ti determina
i determinerà nella tv nello stesso
tempo dobbiamo quindi fare un passo per
non essere schiacciati da tutto questo
allora dobbiamo anzitutto secondo me
partire dalla consapevolezza che non
esiste una libertà assoluta che questi
chiamiamoli tra virgolette
condizionamenti non te ne puoi liberare
totalmente è assolutamente e allora ci
dobbiamo chiedere tutto sbagliato è
tutto negativo se io ambisco una libertà
assoluta tanto non la provo non c'è non
esiste e non come faccio
a prà francesco
una sua un testo è stato un po il suo
testo fondativo le esortazioni
apostoliche vangeli caudium la gioia del
vangelo ha coniato un espressione che è
rimasta nell'ambiente che siano e molto
diciamo usata la realtà è più importante
dell'idea che tra l'altro una delle
quattro espressioni che sintetizzano un
po tutto questo lungo e corposo
documento
se ci guardiamo intorno e vediamo chi
sono i nostri amici chi sono le persone
che ci stanno vicine ci sono pragmatici
e idealistico e di molto sempre concreti
che guarda nella realtà quelli che
vivono un po nel mondo in modo dei sogni
che ai piedi per terra e quelli che
hanno invece la testa fra le nuvole
allora qual è la strada migliore certo
ognuno poi ha fatto come è fatto e
diventa difficile pretendere di cambiare
la propria identità in senso assoluto e
allora
papà francesco in questo testo cielo ce
lo ricorda mi dice la realtà
semplicemente è l'idea si elabora tra le
due si deve instaurare un dialogo
costante evitando che l'idea finisca per
separarsi dalla realtà la realtà è
superiore all idea
e questo implica di evitare diverse
forme di occultamento della realtà
perché peggio ancora e quando questa
realtà non la vediamo chiudiamo gli
occhi mettiamo la testa sotto la sabbia
assolutamente sbagliato
certo papà francesco dice lo dice spesso
che sognare è una buona cosa va bene ma
per andare avanti serve il confronto con
la realtà perché la realtà è esiste e la
realtà significa anche le persone la mia
famiglia il mio paese il paese dove vivo
la storia che mi ha produzion a ta e
così via l'idea è frutto di elaborazione
di elaborazione mentale
che rischia spesso di cadere così nelle
varie ragionamenti
pensiamo anche a tante forme la politica
anche politici purtroppo tante volte
formula hanno progetti
chiari precisi ma che poi non si
realizzano e quindi la sfiducia che ne
deriva da parte anche di tanto in tanto
di noi della cittadinanza anche questa
insomma il principio di realtà che per
noi cristiani almeno questo principio ha
un fondamento chiaro preciso nel mistero
dell'incarnazione di dio si noi crediamo
noi cristiani che che dio si è fatto
uomo che dio
rimanendo di è diventato come uno di noi
come me come voi
immergendoci nella storia e nella
cultura di quel tempo di quel momento
nella cultura del tempo in cui gesù
vissuto gesù è un ebreo del suo tempo
pienamente inserito nella sua storia
allora
credo che a noi come esseri umani spetti
di far questo intanto guardarci intorno
lo ripeto pensarci come in relazione con
gli altri perché nessuno di noi vive da
solo vive chiuso in una bolla e allora
bisogna fare un attento discernimento
per non essere plagiati orientati
negativamente o annullati da alcuni
piuttosto che da altri di questi
condizioni che bisogna guardarsi intorno
e dire ma quali sono le cose
effettivamente negative quelle che mi
fanno male questa è la scelta di libertà
che ogni individuo non solo può ma deve
fare non quella di liberarsi di una
realtà che comunque già esiste prima di
lui e si stacca dopo di lui e che
altrimenti se non ci si mette in una
relazione giusta lo farà vivere ci farà
vivere sempre non ha colto una tensione
in una continua
insoddisfazione e andremo avanti sempre
con quel senso di oppressione che ci fa
sentire che ci manca qualcosa che non
abbiamo che non riusciamo a realizzare e
allora dobbiamo trovare come si dice la
nostra strada fare di tutto affinché
ognuno
persegua quell'obiettivo aiutandoci la
solidarietà che oltre a essere un valore
cristiano un volo romano c'è il fatto
che ci dobbiamo
nonostante le privazioni di questo
periodi questo comode ci dobbiamo dare
la mano gli uni gli altri a sostenerci
adesso lo stiamo vivendo per un'ennesima
volta col tema dell'accoglienza dei
poveri ucraini
che scappano che fuggono da questo
terribile
persecuzione e allora dobbiamo mettere
in relazione la parola condizionamento
la parola sovrastrutture le
sovrastrutture lo dicevo generano i
condizionamenti
elencarli sì potremmo dire come già
accennato quelli della nostra infanzia
da quando nasciamo siamo immersi in
quelle esperienze e ci orientano
l'educazione familiare la scuola lupi
i mezzi di comunicazione
questi sì questi ovviamente se ne parla
tanto se ne discute perché
effettivamente oggi sono diventati un
nuovo mondo una nuova realtà nella quale
tantissimi di voi ci sono tanti giovani
presenti siete immersi anzi come si dice
oggi ci siete nati in quel mondo noi no
noi ci stiamo approcciando a quel mondo
perché senza quel mondo sei fuori
ma nello stesso tempo
chiaramente non cogliamo alcuni aspetti
che voi giovani ma credo in modo
particolare lo dico spesso ai ragazzi
anche gli adolescenti
anche su questo fai un grande
discernimento e questo bisogna imporcelo
decidere di farlo e basta perché
altrimenti non non si va avanti
l'umanità si interroga non solo su come
funzionano le cose ma anche sul perché e
questo proposito un accenno anche
secondo alcuni anche secondo marx visto
che l'ho citato all'inizio la religione
era una sovrastruttura
però la religione l'esperienza della
fede non sono solo una delle
sovrastrutture o presunte tali tra le
altre certo perché non c'è nessuno
anche la persona più laica anche un
credente che non sia chiamato a
interrogarsi
da dove viene e dove va le famose
domande fondamentali perché sono nato
perché esiste il male perché ci sono le
guerre perché un uomo si sveglia la
mattina e decide di distruggere di
uccidere domande che restano che
aleggiano nel
nostro immaginario nostra mente ma anche
che toccava nostra realtà e dicendo
condizionamento diciamo a qualcosa di
negativo dispregiativo
condizionamento a volte un torto un
abuso nei confronti della libertà lo
dicevo ma d'altra parte libertà e
autonomia sono che valori dominanti
della della cultura della cultura in cui
viviamo ben venga guai a non credere in
questo in una libertà che non sia una
libertà astratta mano libertà concreta
quella che mi fa diventare
attore protagonista di una vicenda la
mia vicenda umana quella che svolgo
quello che faccio se sono uno studente
che vado a scuola se sono un lavoratore
faccio il mio lavoro
protagonista proprio spinto da questa da
questo interesse da questa mozione
il condizionamento ovviamente blocca
frena e quindi si esercita verso il
comportamento può andare a livello della
coscienza addirittura lo sappiamo anche
si sente dire dici questo perché sei
condizionato da tua madre oppure pensi
questo perché la tua educazione ti ha
regalato in questo senso ricordo solo un
inciso quando decisi di entrare in
seminario dopo il liceo avevo anche
vent'anni
io ricordo i miei genitori tra
virgolette brave persone ovvero tutto ci
mancherebbe si oppose dicendo se
condizionato dall'ambiente da quello
stile dall'oratorio che frequenta lo
cede
forse io mi sono detto sì forse sarà
così ma io spero che questo
condizionamento per me sia
l'orientamento della scelta migliore
della vita fino ad ora devo dire insomma
pentito ringrazio dio di aver fatto
quella scelta in qualche modo allora
tutto ci condiziona sì la pubblicità la
moda parlavo della comunicazione e anche
qui dobbiamo però veramente sviluppare
la nostra
capacità critica
pensando che che tutto quello che
abbiamo noi lo dobbiamo mettere in gioco
nella maniera migliore non puo fare
questi questi artifici questi voli
pindarici pensando di risolvere tutto da
un punto di vista così decisionale basta
io minias trani mi estraneo della realtà
quasi anche questo l'abbiamo visto nella
storia nella storia del pensiero le
utopie come venivano chiamati vivere in
un mondo diverso in un'isola deserta
ma non funziona non ha non ha funzionato
e non ha mai funzionato tutto questo
anzi invece chiesto di entrarci di
starci dentro in questa realtà anche
quando è nuda e cruda anche quando è una
realtà due aerea questo non significa
andare
ovviamente non avrebbe senso se avesse
senso ben venga farlo anche il coraggio
di muoversi e di fare scelte importanti
quindi spero che insomma è tutto questo
veramente ci aiuti ci faccia pensare che
alla luce delle nostre scelte e alla
luce rosse decisioni nonostante i
condizionamenti un mondo migliore è
possibile anche grazie a tutti quanti
noi a ciascuno di noi
grazie
[Musica]